[Music]
thank you it's a anymore enormous
pleasure for me to be here today and
when I rehearsed and went over the
target first I was wondering whether I
should say something along lines that
I'm not sure whether I'm following mark
under the bus or he's throwing me under
the bus here so we'll see how this turns
out I'm yes I'm a web developer and I
want to start very simple here and the
simplicity here should probably start
with that I only want to say that I've
been a web development for about 20
years now I work for small companies for
medium-sized companies for larger
companies and I had the pleasure to work
freelance and as a consultant and to
work on my own projects and on other
people's projects and all of that and
researching a bit and publishing and
blah blah blah so the only thing I want
to say with that is I I feel grateful
that I got to get to know our field from
a variety of angles and I'm very happy
about that and I'm happy about that
particularly because I think our field
and I like to be liberal with terms
sometimes some people might call that
quite imprecise but I like to call it
liberal that I also love together web
development and web design at times so
here I want to keep up a develop and
focus but don't mind me sometimes
bleeding into web design as well and I
think overall and that is is one thing I
want to emphasize here now in the next
next few minutes is how great of a field
we are in and how great the neighboring
fields are and I'm also thing that I was
wondering about when preparing this was
whether I should really keep this
metaphor that I had in my mind and it's
one that I stole from someone who is
talking to writers and I'd like to read
a lot and I like to pick up books where
on any kind of sub
and as I publish and as I write a lot I
picked up a book about writing and this
book was by Rachel Aaron I believe and
it was one of those heavily promoted
books on Amazon and I read it and I took
a few things out of their overall
contains some nice advice and then one
metaphor stuck in my head because I feel
like not only am a terrible person to
tell jokes I don't always feel like I
can tell good stories and so she used
that metaphor of if you want to tell the
story
you take your characters you put them in
the tree and that is supposed to
symbolize at least you can pick one tree
there and you put it all on fire and
then you try to save your characters and
later thought like is this a good way of
structuring a presentation and I didn't
think about it any further that happens
and so I will start with that we will
put some things into a tree and there
are five things or families of things I
want to emphasize in this first part
things I find exciting about our field
about web development and design and
also when starting to prepare I thought
like well the first thing to notice is
like how it's really easy to get into a
field the first thing to come to my mind
was that there's low equipment cost for
instance anything with the screen would
do with any computer with the screen
would do that seems a bit very simple so
I thought the next good thing would
probably be that is really easy for us
to start get into all field and I've
made the mistakes in earlier years that
whenever people approached me about how
do I learn web development how do I
learn web design I scared them by
telling them with dispatch go and read
the specifications and then people
normally left and went elsewhere and
it's still something that I try to not
give this advice anymore but what I like
about this is if you think about other
industries and other fields then you
notice that oftentimes it's much more
obscure and much more expensive
to actually get to excellent sources in
order to learn a craft and I think we're
in a kind of a where at first I thought
I'd like privilege but that would push
it probably but we're in a great
situation that we do actually sit on
heaps of materials of excellent quality
for free so specifications and RFC's dry
as they may be they're still excellent
in order to start getting into our field
and then for practicing that of course
is also very important for us in order
to actually learn our craft and for
practicing they are also hosts of
interesting options I think and the
first one probably being that it's very
easy to just work with local tests and
local files so we can fire up textile to
a key in doctype HTML title fool P bar
and as you can tell like I'm alluding to
a very simplest simple form but valid
form of HTML that you can then save and
open your browser and then you see like
bar like as we just get in the content
for paragraph very simple to really stay
by the way whenever I want to test
something CSS or something like that I
just work with static files local files
local testify it's very simple and quick
to do and then another thing then that
is I think in a nice peculiarity or
characteristic for a field are of course
that we can use and work with our own
websites and if I can get a quick show
of hands who here has their own website
that is a good number and and and and I
feel like you will all know from your
own experience then how this doesn't
just start with the practice that you
get by running your own website but it
starts a thing with a deeper commitment
so you own your own site you feel
responsible for it you feel committed to
it and then it starts all that practice
that you get and be it that you start
and that by the way these days is my
recommendation really for people who
want to get into a field to actually
start with our one website because of
the commitment because of the practice
we get even when it's just a business
card type page even that can be useful
the commitment the options that we have
to try things to design to code to
to work with something that we own and
that we identify with to some degree or
fully not too much and then they of
course like we have other people's
website and I think ironically at first
I thought like I make a snarky remark
about that how we run other people's
website and sometimes bad things happen
there but that would be a bit too much
because normally very good things happen
with that because yes we do practice and
yes we also sometimes we need that as a
playground to in order to grow and learn
as professionals this is this is useful
but hones our skills and we're mostly in
the line of working with other people's
sites and so they are like all these
practice opportunities which I believe
are actually unique about our field the
really special thing then about web
development in design then I think is
the great power it really comes with and
also at first I thought about should I
go and talk a bit about full-stack stuff
and I do struggle a bit with that term
and I lose struggled a bit with that
term when I pick up books again I said
like I like to pick up random things and
there was this book lately a great list
of resources about front-end development
and the author tried to define full
stack development and said like well
it's really hard to define but that is
of course not a real definition man for
something but it felt like to me like
yes that is a bit unclear and the worst
thing for me was always the implications
a term like this may have for quality if
quality is a priority for work because
if you have a blurry term and you throw
in a host of technologies then does that
all imply that person is an expert in
all these technologies would be an
interesting thing but it's not that
important here we because I think we
have a much better term and much more
interesting term and a much more
powerful term that we can inherit
ironically from the agency world where
it's about full service and I find full
service really really really interesting
because so full service first and
foremost means in the agency ROM if
someone needs an web
or a nap you develop a concept you
design your code you deploy and you
launch you monitor your optimize and if
you're lucky I'd like to be a bit
cynical about things when you are lucky
then that's also it also gets maintained
of course in the agency world this is
tricky because normally you need
maintenance contracts and blah blah blah
but maintenance in the agency world to
me seems always a bit tricky and
difficult but more from a client angle
actually than from a agency angle
because from the client side you need to
think about maintenance going down the
road in many cases but back to full
service as professionals as people
working in our fields we many of us are
ventured to say work either for agencies
at some point in their career or the way
with agencies at some point in the
career or their run their own websites
as we've just seen like many of us here
and in these capacities we do touch on
this I believe we are all familiar with
this to some degree we all write some
concept or have some idea about
something conceptual at times we do
design we develop when we have this
development focus of course we do code
and we bring stuff online and we monitor
and we optimize and we mark it in
everything so I think all of us have a
full-service kind of profile and yes to
varying degrees some of us are well
let's assume like developers will
normally have their strengths there some
of us have also sake design background
or even stronger there and others will
find it easier to say optimize something
whether that's for search engines or for
conversion or whatnot and then others
like yeah have again different profiles
for me personally I guess I tend to
always overestimate my design
capabilities but I'm definitely very
sure that I have no marketing talent so
there I know where I stand in the full
service run a little bit at least the
thing again is the power now so when we
have an idea about something about an
app or insight we are in the situation
that for us we we can quite possibly
actually execute it
quality considerations left aside now or
at least we know for the things that we
can't do who we can contact who we can
work with what we can do and we all
probably know people like who approach
us and say hey I have this idea about
this app or site and then they talk
about the idea and we feel like ah
sounds kind of interesting maybe you
want to contribute in some in some way
and then we don't have the time or they
wouldn't know it's just not financially
interesting or anything like that and
then months later we meet them again and
nothing has happened because they are
literally I think we meet people like
that they have great ideas but they
don't have any idea where to start they
don't know what to do they don't even
know how to ask well apparently they ask
us and we should know and we could
probably do something if we have the
time of the interest and stuff but the
point here is that we are actually in
the situation to execute on that and I
think this is one of the greatest things
about being in our field like what a
unique situation and position we are in
and then there's complexity and at first
that might sound odd right I mean
completely it doesn't exactly sound like
something to be excited about but I
believe it is because actually thinking
about I used to work as a factory line
worker at some point as a summer job and
after day one or two I didn't need this
belt anymore that other people were
using Spurs for the schools and stuff
not to say that I was so quick or
something like that the work was so damn
boring that I was adding excitement by I
don't know like changing the way that I
walked around the line and stuff like
that in order to work on this and there
were people like working on this for 20
years and then it's most of the students
working there were already fed up with
his after two hours so it was really
interesting to see that now we are
certainly not in the field like that but
there is literally so much complexity
that I think it challenges us in very
interesting and very constructive and
very useful ways and I actually believe
we should accept these challenges
sometimes to meet people who are a bit
fed up like oh my gosh web development
last 20 years changed so much like a
are these things and then they don't
want to then they don't feel motivated
anymore and they regret like that things
have changed the way they change but I
think we should accept that and we can't
even feel excited about it and it also
has a little story in the early 2000s I
was working for a Java software company
that was the only in in-house web
developer I was working on the corporate
side and I worked on client side and
these were the days
the really dark days were even Netscape
4 had to be considered and there was a
e5 and ie6 and nothing really worked and
compatibility issues and support issues
and still days where we had tightened
the grip on HTML because we all wanted
to write this strict XHTML and we wanted
to use those hundred properties that we
had in CSS and now we're approaching 400
or something like that which really like
is not just linear growth like things
got really complex with CSS and I'm
really torn or whether I should get
started on that or not but complexity so
I was bored I was like okay I approached
one of the founders I'm like last I want
to become a software developer and that
is actually one thing I wouldn't say now
and I I wanted to be a software
developer and he's like sure we pair you
up with our programmers and here are
some things you can work on here's a
book and I started reading Bruce echo of
things thinking on Java I don't I don't
even show how many thinking on books he
has written and I started doing that and
I was just lucky that I started reading
other books I start reading steve cooks
don't make me think and Nielsen's
homepage usability and then Stanford
University speech at Fox book on
persuasive technology which is really
interesting book still about
human-computer interaction I read Robert
bring us elements of typographic style
and also a lot of books by Edward Tufte
on information design and I can highly
recommend Tufte really because not just
for our field as professionals but in
general because we deal with information
design in a lot of other places of
course in the media and in newspapers
and there is astonishing degree of
problems like with graphs and charts and
they sometimes distort the information
that we really get and I think Tufte
gives a nice very pleasant access to
this matter so it's quite enjoyable to
do and to actually learn about this
subject and all the books that are
listed I think like we most of us would
have read one of those books if not more
or all of them so they're really
excellent books and I was just lucky
that I ran into all this excellent
literature and yes it's not development
stuff but I realized wow this isn't
boring there is actually so much more to
our field and it all relates to my in
our work so for me of course back then
it was this personal decision like that
I want to stay in web development I
wanted to I want to get out of there and
I stayed and it was that moment where I
realized no this is not boring there's a
lot of complexity and this is really
challenging this is really interesting
this is really cool and and I believe
well the excitement carries me through
each day yeah so complexity then now as
we progress from how we get into our
field to discovering and acquiring
powers to getting to appreciate the
complexity of our field then we see that
we can also give back and I see prime to
prime ways of giving back to the
community into the field and that is one
on the eye and one in one hand that is
open contributed to open source projects
and then to doing translation work and
if I can get some hints again like who
you contributes or has contribute to
open source projects and who here
contributes with translations this is
cool like I suspected that on the
translation and we might be a few if it
might be fewer people but I think this
is actually really this is a very
interesting piece because we are and we
are getting to learn more about
accessibility I think today like we are
actually making content accessible so
we're we're helping that more people can
get
- let's hope excellent information so
whenever you read an excellent article
or whenever we read the super boring
spec we can go out and translate it and
make it available in our mother tongue
or whatever we are capable of speaking
and that is great and then of course we
can
so apart from making that accessible we
and helping helping the field this way
and helping the projects this way of
course like if when we run our website
we host the contents there we sometimes
get a nice kick back to just as this
extra incentive if we then choose or if
that's important for us on the other
hand for open source contributions there
the only thing that i want to point out
probably is that there's no - no change
or no contribution that is too small i
believe it's very important or does not
it's not necessary that we become
full-time contributors to a project but
that small edits like whether that's
fixing typos improving code snippets and
so on go a long way actually and
contributing and helping other people
and other projects and for me personally
that means whenever I focus posit Ori
and gold over something and I have
routine checks and routine scripts go
over my codebase and something to say
that would compress images or something
like that I would play that back into
the repository and I think these small
things are absolutely legitimate and
they help so it's not needed that we say
become like yeah again like we know that
we invested a few hours every week in
order to become like really like strong
contributors and supporters of an
open-source project this can be simple
things and small things that we can
contribute and I think this is pretty
awesome about our field that we can
actually do this so that we have this
option to give back and then as a fifth
point that I want our family of points
if you want that like to call out is
also that option we share this with
other fields of course but it's still a
bit different for us the option that we
publish our ideas or commentary or
research that we can do this again
another benefit when we run our on side
we can do this there
and then we can do this for magazines
and we can do this for publishers and we
have a great opportunity there are great
possibilities there in order to again
like Lowe learn and grow through
teaching in a way and then also to build
a reputation this way and I find that's
unique and if not for the medium because
this is our medium and they are probably
more options and easier and simpler
options for us to go out there and
publish than this for other fields we
have several advantages there with these
things I want to close this first part
and move on to setting everything up on
fire and the way I want to do this is
actually not analogous like I will not
take the points that I made earlier and
try to refute them or anything like that
but I rather like to say to do is like
take some perhaps different aspects one
for instance practice thing and that is
actually the big topic actually because
practice is really important for us I
hope we can agree on this it's important
that we touch code as developers need to
be able to code and as designers we
should also be able to design something
now and it's clear to us that when
someone registers the domain a dreamhost
there's a one-click install of WordPress
goes to Squarespace and generates the
logo goes to peloton and generates some
colors and then goes back and downloads
the theme and changes some colors and
updates the logo at that's not a
developer or a designer
anyone can do that and of course what
I'm referring to is an entire line of
business that allows people to set up
sites like that but we have similar
situations in other ways in other
aspects of our work because if you want
to really push it on the other extreme
if as developers we just go and write
our CSS write some selectors some
declarations we test and then well off
we go pre process or Linzer who cares
and I am it's a great of course but if
you think about it then
what is a difference really so we leave
everything that is related to the craft
really to tools because anyone here not
anyone here anyone outside we could ask
like hey this is the basic syntax of a
stud sheet how about you go and write
something in the question sometimes it's
like is that is there a noticeable
difference then they might struggle a
bit like finding like the declarations
that they need in order to do something
and of course it will take some work but
what is the difference really if at the
end of the day at the end of the our
work we leave everything else up to the
tools like cleaning it up sorting it
like optimizing it in whatever fashion
and I do not want to say that hours way
of writing CSS this way is so so wrong
and I will not make suggestions here but
it goes beyond that we have other tools
that do similar things for us and the
trickiest thing is we want that to not
just because of convenience but we
actually go out there and this is a page
of the Google book where at least where
I picked it up it's like whenever you
see things being done repeatedly and you
can automate them then go and automate
like for efficiency and productivity
that is really important and that
there's a conflict there so if we go and
try to automate everything and try to
use tools for everything use scripts
anywhere then that has an impact on our
craft and we need to be aware of this
that's probably all I want to say here
this is one danger that we need to watch
out for and I've at some point pushed
out this idea certainly not new
certainly not just coming from me this
idea that we need to make our lives
difficult at times and this is not
something that any one of us can tell
the other person because we need to be
honest enough that we notice and see
where we struggle where we can't do well
enough in order to then decide we don't
use tools for these things but we
understand the technology and we
understand how to really do it on
ourselves and for me as an example I
like to focus one of my the areas that
I'd like to focus on a lot is my
it's a maintainability and I
intentionally I'm not a masochist well
no sometimes maybe but for some projects
I don't use a content management system
nor a static site generator or anything
like that I've maintained it manually
and I have one side I think very small
fortunately thankfully 38 languages and
I maintain it all by hand and this is
painful but it is painful in a good way
because when I notice that I [ __ ] up
then okay I learned something this is
not the script running in the background
then compiled sin or I have just one
piece where I change it now
intentionally made it a bit harder for
myself so that I know when I screw
something up that I feel the pain so
that it is not a tool remedying or like
that I never noticed that as well in the
first place or worse in a team
environment that somebody up as cleans
up the stuff that I've I've done and
this is an example for that so where we
intentionally make our lives more
difficult where we focus on practice
where we focus on actually really
understanding and mastering our craft
also thing that I've not not even
alluded to but you can see that clearly
I think in the power camp our industry
and our field allow us to work alone
you can work freelance and self-employed
and you can even as a consultant I think
you can spend a lot of time alone and
then worse and I really like I don't
make this a topic here but I think there
are some problems around that worse we
romanticize and we glorify this idea of
the digital and the global.nomads you
can just work anywhere just go to the
Caribbean and handle your client
projects we say this is like great this
is an idea this is like the ideal worker
these days and I'm exaggerating again
just for the emphasis but there are
problems to that and I'm not talking
about like what this wheaty does with
you like whether it's really that
favorable and desirable to leave your
your friends and family but the thing is
when we work alone on stuff and when we
work alone on stuff for an extended
period of time there is a chance
that we forego any kind of criticism and
criticism in the sense of scrutiny not
in a sense of negative feedback by all
means just scrutiny and we know that
pair programming peer reviews code
reviews are useful for that reason just
so that we have an eye on each other
like that we can check like us they're
something that we can do better or is
there something obviously wrong or
something like that up to the point
where we outright escape reality and
that probably sounds don't ever you have
a good example for that but I guess you
can really push it very far and so it's
something that we need to watch out for
that when we work alone this is an
option that we have it comes as a perk
of our field and we will see at a later
point than to like how it is actually
also very tempting to do that but how
it's something we need to watch out for
that we need to a guard ourselves
against and then the power in general
and this guy having no limits and
actually there should probably say we
obviously have touched on the point of
choice where you can work alone in
freelance where you can hire with
agencies or multinationals or you can
try a lot of things in our field up to
founding companies and we see great
examples for companies in even like in
web design and development if I think
about Jim doing Germany for instance or
Wix in the US for instance companies
that of course like Target like people
like wanna run websites and we are in
that business and so on I find these are
interesting examples for companies that
are successful think they actually have
the ups and downs but it's examples for
where we can push a very development of
the design centric idea of our
profession and so what happens there is
and I don't necessarily see that and
observe that that much when it comes to
career choices that people are literally
waiting for months to decide whether
they want to work freelance or whether
they want to work for a company but we
see this I think on technology and to
choices and then also on work when
people when we work on our own projects
that we lose focus that it's that builds
power that we can't do anything needs so
that we actually do anything
and there's problematic and with that
comes some sense of inertia to that
sometimes we get a bit slower because
first we need to evaluate this and that
and maybe how do we choose and things
like that so there are effects of this
and then in the next aspect the
complexity of our field now we now we
get to some of the drawbacks that is
really obscure now what's right or wrong
and then the technically wrong as we
know there often is right or wrong
sometimes there isn't there a good
member of questions and I think we are
then venturing more in design and
usability and preferences and so on you
don't have a right or wrong but for some
technical questions you can clearly say
something performs or works better than
the other but it's got a really really
difficult now to tell when that is the
case and I would venture to say that
this affects us as experts as
professionals just as much as anyone
else like you better than we are junior
or more expert or more senior and I
think there are two reasons for that
one thing is like something I think we
all struggle with in a way and that is
probably the simpler reason that it's
really hard to tell like who is an
expert how do we judge that is that like
that person has published something or
worked for a company or has written this
project or like what is it how did we
tell like whether a person like really
has a point somewhere and maybe we find
out we can't really tell that because we
can all make mistakes and of course on
the other side of the spectrum there are
good points that junior developers and
junior members of our field do or make
you make so we sometimes get feedback
from people who aren't really long in
our field and they can make excellent
remarks and point us to things that we
have completely overlooked so the
expertise thing is one thing the other
thing then and I will try to not make
this too academic because I don't think
that would help us that much but there
is a problem in the way we argue and I
will give an example all sort of a fear
or an area dear to me and that's
frameworks development and you can
perfectly imagine a person a saying hey
yes absolutely use a frame always
because you can quickly get something
out of the ground you can quickly work
your project and quickly
whether this is working or not proof of
concept and then you get a person like
me who says like oh my gosh I please do
not use the framework because sooner or
later you want and well you want a
tailor a framework an external framer
can never know what you intend to do
with inside so it comes with too much
code if it come more often enough comes
with too much code and too little
because obviously you pick the stuff
that covers your needs but always cover
more than those so cut has blowed in
there is this thus it's not efficient as
thus it has therefore big performance
issues and there are also security
problems with that if you're always
continuously hooking up to third-party
services or servers or something like
that always need to watch for a third
party now you have these two persons and
they tell you something contradictory
once says don't use them yeah that says
do use them and of course like we
already see what's the problem here
because the premises and the goals are
different the person like favoring and
advocating frameworks and let it be
something else too like could be
libraries or some of that tree saying
like here speed of execution is
important and proof of concept and the
other person says like no quality is
important and security so premises are
different the next thing there is like
we need one I guess like this is fairly
easy to follow but it is something that
we need to keep in mind both as
recipients when we follow arguments and
then also as the ones bringing them
forth when we write we need to be clear
that the that is important that we make
clear the premises of our arguments what
are we after and then we can still run
into situations where you read five - we
get five different expert opinions they
are all different and they are all right
and then you have other aspects where of
course are you have several people you
they all give you some answers and
they're all wrong and it's just
difficult to tell and I think we perhaps
just need to acknowledge that it's
gotten really hard now and that we stay
careful when it comes to judging
solutions and judges in common
and judging of use because of exactly
the situation so it's important that we
keep in mind that we argue properly and
I don't think like since this is really
something you can dive in academically
where it's about like the law good
logical construction of arguments that
this is probably not a problem that goes
away that so not in the landscape that
we're in right now will we face that
tone of complexity the different
technologies different tools the
different philosophies the different
approaches the different mindsets etc
and then the fifth point I want to make
here where we put everything on fire is
that instant publishing it's nice that
it is as it is to get a kick out of
publishing something on our website the
kick we get out of publishing an article
for magazine the kick that we get from
publishing our first book or the second
or whatever that this is also something
to guard against because yes we probably
get some review stand at later stages it
seaming it must make some sense what
we're saying and what we're doing and
probably something useful in there but
it is a problem too because we get this
gratification we get this kick but it is
also a danger that it messes with us in
a way that we think like there is
something more to our work that we are
somewhat special and this I want to use
to actually quickly jump to the next
points where we try to get ourselves out
of this situation and I can already say
I don't have five points again only
three more and they're also not exact
matches to what I've just described
we've seen I hope that our field and our
neighboring fields are really special
and I think they really are that the
thing is we are not and it's funny
because I do not want to make this Habib
psychologist thing and I don't believe
much in this idea that we say oh now we
are all special and then we're not again
or something like that and then we get
into some I don't know where you end up
then but this is where this is going
when you start arguing this way of
course we are valuable and we are people
and everything
but our field gives us unique
opportunities very unique advantages but
it's not that this makes like we're
special in the sense that we also
entitled and I think entitlement these
days is a really important thing to keep
in mind and I need to caution myself now
not so again like get on this track of
hobby psychology here but there are
these indications and these the ideas
that whenever we look around in society
people for actually very for quite
opposite reasons actually the people who
are doing really really well seem to
feel really entitled about everything
you need special treatment and then we
also have people that go do really
really bad puddi
and they also feel entitled and they
also feel any special treatment and we
have that and I want to stop my
commentary on that there because what do
I know but the thing is it is something
that I think affects us too there are
unique options and opportunities in our
field you need powers that come with it
okay let's just be grateful for this the
other thing that I think we can look at
more closely is focus and I want to
start with a little story there I picked
up the book by Gary Keller last year
it's called the one thing nothing is
also pretty popular and I read this book
and I'm like ok awesome focus and the
idea is really like you pick in your
work life and in your personal life and
cetera maybe lots of for your day you
pick you one thing that you want to
focus on the basic the essence of the
book is pretty simple so what does Yin's
do i sit down and open up a spreadsheet
and as a self-employed person working on
my own stuff i'm like i'm listing all
the different things that i'm doing and
come up with this list of 50 items say
ends okay a focus and i was marking
through and acting out like these things
that weren't important or fun like yeah
they're not important ended up with a
list of 45 items
that is not focus and it took me
actually a major personal earthquake
earlier this year where things were
pretty shitty and I was like I already
work on stuff right now
but for some reason I need to I need to
do some things and I was looking at the
different things that I was doing and
thinking about them and also like
feeling a bit more like where's my heart
at because I was trying all sorts of
[ __ ] and stuff and projects here and
there because when you're self-employed
and when you really look into making
your living and we again we have these
options right we can focus on content
size affiliate marketing the people
making thousands of yours with that so
why not do these test balloons and it's
looking at it and end up with two or
three things I was like okay yeah that
okay but didn't set how to get through a
major crisis but at least I'm focused
now and I do not wish this to anyone
else here that is necessary or and I
want to suggest that it's important for
us to go through any kind of crisis in
order to get there but I do believe and
I strongly believe that it is important
for us to focus that we are aware of
where are our priorities
and by the way things again of course as
always they depend they get more subtle
for instance if you are a junior
developer designer or member of our
field it does make sense to try things
to cast a wider net try things don't be
too focused I said look at everything
but the ones for the worse more senior
here I think it is important that we
focus that we know what is really
important what are the projects we need
to look at what are the technologies you
want to be really good at so what is it
that really matters and where is our
heart at I think this is really crucial
and then lastly this is odd thing too
and I will try to explain this just a
bit because we've already talked about
working alone and stuff like that and
also what the options that we have on
our field like do with us and for me try
to think whether this is such a useful
start but I'll try it this way
in my time at Google
and there's a high performance
environment never really struggled there
it's not to say that I can do all these
things that easily know the reason why I
didn't struggle and I only noticed this
years later was that I had already
carved out a niche I have my
specializations and I suspect many of
you too - you specialize in something
and the interesting thing about
specialization is it's actually a very
smart way of evading escaping
competition because when you're a
specialist in something and when you
work in an environment where is the only
evident be when you're the only person
doing this stuff so it doesn't mean that
Honda and the whole planet you're the
only person doing this know but suffice
is if in your company or new team you're
the only person doing something your
specialist and it's harder to compete
against you and what I'm saying trying
to say is and I need to start another
threat here there's an XM Popovic home
called no contest and not only does he
argue that we as humans aren't
inherently competitive rather the
opposite we have cooperated we get where
we are and we got where we are through
working together to cooperate and I deem
it actually really terrible thing when
we keep on telling ourselves these
stories that we are all competitive that
we would eat ourselves alive and all
that stuff I think this is yes we are
cooperative so now when you look at it
if we assume that we are cooperative and
then another point corn mate we are in
an environment full of structural
competition as he calls it we're in
education in the workplace in society
you have all these circumstances that
force you to compete with your fellow
beings humans the English leaves media
mention that's bad news so I mean we all
need to be better and we all get
compared and judged and assessed and so
on I think this is terrible
and for me it was funny like because I
noticed like I am invited I'm taking on
competition I don't mind competing I
don't want to but if somebody is pushing
me I compete whether then I think the
strategy is nice if you think about you
specialize where you work alone on
things and so on because you're
competing in a way but you're also not
and then as we've seen like some other
issues come up because you isolate
yourself in a professional level and so
on
you have different issues then so the
point that I try to make here is just
let let's not fix the world here I have
no idea how what we are supposed to do
about structural competition in the
workplace no idea that's not my cup of
tea really but it is important for us I
think to be aware of this and to look at
it and figure out like okay well maybe
it affects us at least acknowledge that
closing there I want to really with the
what I wanted with it what to do with it
opening remarks and with what I've
spilled in here and there that our field
web development design and also the
neighboring professions are awesome
they're fantabulous like it's really fun
there are a lot of lots of great things
about our fields like the what we learn
there the opportunities that we have
like the growth paths that we see there
the many options I think that are
fantabulous so that's all I want to
really say now and that's why I'm
personally also very excited now to see
all the other talks and to be here
beyond tell her that now for today and
tomorrow thank you